foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hi this is James page at the ftth
conference meeting in Madrid I'm With
Yuri matsuk who's from the Ukraine
Department of digital transformation at
Yuri thank you for coming over to us
um the networks in Ukraine have stayed
remarkably resilient despite the obvious
difficulties how have you have you
managed to keep everything running so
well
available operators realized your
problem with base station which lose the
United and set up internal roaming it
means when some operators lose base
station customer can use network from in
other operators and make calling for
your family for you know work
then government got the frequencies
without pay and government called off
the pay for electricity pillars and
start of the full-scale war all
customers use internet access
when they don't have pay for services
okay so it's been remarkably important
to stay connected during the conflict
but you're already also thinking about
the future and and the recovery effort
when you're talking to people here at
the ftth or
um talking to European commission and
National governments what sort of things
are you asking them how can they help
you with the recovery effort
I was thinking about some projects
launched some project for Recovery of
recruiting we discussed about it from
digiconnect from some presence from
people who connected with government of
Germany maybe with government of Britain
and to the government of Ukraine started
pilot project for Recovery five villages
which Full destroyed
and we need to make the better place
after the war in these villages
we want
to our people to come at home lives in
Ukraine and from abroad
okay that's fantastic so your message to
um to the British government and any
others is is is is is what how is there
anything specific that they should be
doing to support you at the moment
uh yes uh a lot of government support uh
uh I I think about uh starlinks uh we we
got from government of Poland uh nearly
50 000 Sterling from government of uh uh
Germany nearly 10 000 certainly in some
something equipment from government of
Britain and uh different uh companies
private companies we got a lot of
donations from uh from England and from
Britain uh to recovery Network in the
not on the territories after the
occupation
okay well look thank you so much for
coming and talk to us it's amazing to to
hear about what's what's going on and we
hope you have a successful conference
for all of your aims and appreciate you
taking the time to come and talk to us
oh yes it's very appreciated time uh
it's a new contacts it's new persons
which make a lot of good good things for
growth internet access we think about
the better place in Ukraine with
internet access because we have after
the war we have maybe the best coverage
in Europe 90 of people who can use the
highest
use high speed internet access with
mobile it is fixed access I think we do
all share in in those aims so Yuri thank
you so much for talking to us
thank you for you too
[Music]
[Applause]